hi i'm ray dalio as you might know my  objective at this stage of my life  is to pass along the principles  perspectives and tools that have helped  me  ever since i published the free  principles in action  app last year on the apple us app store  i've been getting a lot of requests from  people on android  and in other countries to have it  available for them  i'm excited to let you know that as of  today  the principles in action app is now  available  on both apple and android in the united  states the uk  india spain and germany and we expect to  add it to other countries  it's received a 4.9 rating so people  love it and i hope that you will love it  as well  please give me feedback on social media  so you can help me make it better for  you